j'ai vu que tu j'aime bien son renard
mort sur la tête on te touche rarement
on a vraiment
ah bon
j'accueille maintenant Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
Stéphane Guillaume messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on t'écoute fils bien père
alors hier Thierry c'était la journée
mondiale contre la maladie d'Alzheimer
oui c'est ça c'était c'était hier
une maladie grave une seule tentative de
vaccin qui s'est soldé par 18 cas dans
ces phalides heureusement les malades ne
portent pas plainte ils se souviennent
pas qu'on les axés
[Applaudissements]
OK
un mâle sournois qui peut frapper la
France entière exemple Jacques Martin
tout le monde l'avait oublié et puis
cette semaine patatras tout le monde
s'en souvient sous vos applaudissements
mesdames et messieurs merci
notamment France 2 qui après avoir viré
l'animateur en 98 la reprogrammée
dimanche dernier comme à la grande
époque un espoir pour tous les
animateurs une fois mort on peut
retrouver sa case
[Applaudissements]
mémoire toujours dimanche c'était la
journée du patrimoine la veille c'était
la journée contre le cancer de la
prostate à cette occasion notre document
de la semaine un monument qui a perdu sa
prostate
[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup moi
sur la tête on te touchera rarement on a
vraiment bien
[Applaudissements]
lundi il fallait y penser c'était le
troisième tiers provisionnel pour les
860 000 malades d'Alzheimer qui ont
oublié ses 10% en plus
[Applaudissements]
alzheimer une maladie terrible à 47 ans
50% des cerveaux présenteraient des
lésions voici un grand malade
le 17 mars il déclare la solution c'est
le vote Ségolène Royal 6 mois après
Ségolène n'est pas taillée pour le rôle
un centre Alzheimer doit accueillir les
vieux socialistes entre ceux qui
trahissent et ceux qui crachent dans la
soupe l'unité devrait fonctionner à bloc
il s'en fout n'est pas socialiste alors
il est quoi
ailleurs ailleurs dans les étoiles
des malades recensés dans le showbiz
Marc-Olivier Fogiel serait touché sinon
pourquoi VSD publie cette semaine son
emploi du temps
à part lui tout le monde s'en branle
mémoire que j'ouvre
souvenons-nous que cette semaine
l'Assemblée a voté le recours au test
ADN c'est vrai évitons le bordel après
on a un président français d'origine
hongroise qui se balade avec les filles
de Jacques Martin comme si c'était les
siennes
avertissement aux enfants de 100 papiers
ne confondez pas Brice de Nice avec
Brice ortefeu
la casse pour faire rire l'autre brise
définitivement
[Applaudissements]
bon conclusion
en conclusion Thierry Alzheimer est une
maladie très grave il y a des cas
tragiques comme celui-ci Bernard
ancien pacifiste et militants socialiste
il bosse aujourd'hui avec la droite et
veut casser la gueule à tout le monde la
dernière chose bien qui lui reste c'est
Christine Ockrent pourvu pourvu qu'il ne
la quitte pas pour Evelyne Thomas
la semaine prochaine merci et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu